KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE WITH
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
IT HAPPENED AGAIN.
ANOTHER PACKAGE BOMB EXPLODED IN
TEXAS TODAY, A STATE ON HIGH
THIS ONE SET OFF AT A FEDEX
FACILITY NEAR SAN ANTONIO.
ON MARCH 2ND, A 39-YEAR-OLD
FATHER KILLED BY A BOMB MAILED
TO HIS HOUSE IN AUSTIN.
TWO DAYS LATER, TO SIMILAR
ATTACKS.
THE FOURTH BOMB WENT ON SUNDAY,
ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD IN A
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD AND
RIGGED WITH A TRIPWIRE.
TWO PEOPLE WERE HURT.
EARLY THIS MORNING, A FIFTH
EXPLOSION AT A FEDEX FACILITY.
ONE WORKER WAS INJURED.
AN INTENSE MANHUNT IS CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY BEFORE THE KILLER OR
KILLERS THE STRIKE AGAIN.
>> THE BOMBINGS IN AUSTIN ARE
TERRIBLE.
LOCAL, STATE, AND FEDERAL ARE
WORKING HAND-IN-HAND TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY, VERY
SICK INDIVIDUAL OR NAVY
INDIVIDUALS.
THESE ARE SICK PEOPLE.
AND WE WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT.
>> Kimberly: JOINING US FROM
AUSTIN, TEXAS, CASEY STEGALL HAS
BEEN CLOSELY FOLLOWING THIS
UNSOLVED MYSTERY.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL AND BE
WITH YOU.
THINGS TOOK A VERY DIFFERENT
TURN TO A WHEN THESE UNEXPLODED
DEVICES WERE FOUND AT FEDEX
DISTRIBUTION LOCATIONS.
AT LEAST ONE WE HAVE CONFIRMED
FOR SURE.
THAT MEANS NOW INSTEAD OF
SOMEONE JUST PLACING THESE ON
SOMEONE'S DOORSTEP LIKE WE
PREVIOUSLY SAW OR PUTTING IT IN
A RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD WITH
A TRIPWIRE, WHICH IS WHAT WE SAW
HERE ON SUNDAY, THIS IS WHERE IT
GETS DIFFERENT.
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE
PHYSICALLY PUTTING A PACKAGE
INTO THE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM.
THEY GO TO GIANT PLACES LIKE
THIS ONE BACK HERE, MULTIPLE
FEDEX LOCATIONS ACROSS CENTRAL
TEXAS BEING INVESTIGATED AND WE
WANT TO KIND OF BREAK THEM DOWN
FOR YOU.
THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING PARTS
AND A LOT OF CONFLICTING
INFORMATION, FRANKLY, THAT'S OUT
THERE.
THIS IS A BIG LOCATION RIGHT
HERE IN AUSTIN AND IT'S ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF AUSTIN-BERGSTROM
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT.
OFFICIALS SAY A SUSPICIOUS
PACKAGE WAS FOUND HERE THIS
MORNING AND IT HAS CLOSED THE
WHOLE THING DOWN.
SPENCER, IF YOU COULD, MY
PHOTOGRAPHER, GO TO THE MOBILE
COMMAND UNIT BACK THERE BECAUSE
WE SHOULD POINT OUT THERE WAS NO
EXPLOSION HERE.
JUST A SUSPICIOUS PACKAGE.
THE MOBILE COMMAND UNIT, AWESOME
POLICE A VERY BIG PRESENCE HERE
IN ADDITION TO ATF AND FBI
AGENTS.
NOW, THE SECOND LOCATION, THAT'S
IN SCHERTZ WHICH IS NEAR
SAN ANTONIO.
A SCHERTZ DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
THAT'S WHERE THE PACKAGE
EXPLODED THIS MORNING WHEN IT
WAS GOING DOWN A CONVEYOR BELT.
YOU IMAGINE THOSE BIG AMAZON
DISTRIBUTION SITES AND THE
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE,
ALL THE MAIL AND PACKAGES SORTED
ON THOSE BELTS, IT WAS GOING
DOWN ONE OF THOSE BELTS
APPARENTLY WHEN IT WENT OFF.
FORTUNATELY NO ONE WAS RIGHT
NEXT TO IT.
NO SERIOUS INJURIES.
THERE WAS SOME INITIAL TALK
ABOUT A SECOND PACKAGE THAT WAS
FOUND AT THAT LOCATION.
IT DID NOT DETONATE.
BUT THAT IT MAY BE CONTAINED
EXPLOSIVE MATERIAL.
POLICE HAVE SINCE WALKED BACK
BACK AT ME AND SAID NOW ONLY ONE
PACKAGE WAS FOUND THAT LOCATION,
THE ONE THAT WENT OFF.
THEN WE HAVE A THIRD SPOT.
THAT IS IN SUNSET VALLEY, WHICH
IS ONLY 2 MILES OR SO FROM
SUNDAY NIGHT'S CRIME SCENE.
SCENE.
OFFICIALS IN SUNSET VALLEY HAVE
ROPED OFF A FEDEX STORE THERE
AND THE THOUGHT IS THE PACKAGE
THAT EXPLODED AT THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER DOWN NEAR
SAN ANTONIO, THAT IT MIGHT HAVE
ORIGINATED FROM THAT LOCATION.
AGAIN, ONLY 2 MILES FROM
SUNDAY'S SCENE.
IT IS A LITTLE CONFUSING.
YOU HAVE MULTIPLE LOCATIONS,
MULTIPLE VICTIMS, AND A WHOLE
LOT OF CONCERN BECAUSE AGAIN,
THIS IS A CITY ON ALERT.
SOME 420 CALLS OF SUSPICIOUS
PACKAGES CAME IN 10911 JUST IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS, ACCORDING TO
AUSTIN POLICE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE IT IS STRAINING
THE RESOURCES.
>> Kimberly: WE HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
>> Dana: CASEY, WHAT'S THE
ADVICE TO THE CITIZENS THERE
BECAUSE 420 PACKAGES.
IF YOU GET THAT MANY CALLS
COMMITS GOING TO TAKE A WHILE
FOR THE POLICE TO GET THERE.
>> RIGHT, BUT THEY ARE WANTING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DOCKED
THEIR I'S AND CROSS THEIR T'S.
THAT'S WHY GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND
OTHERS HAVE DIVERTED
LAW-ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 500 FEDERAL
AGENTS ALONE.
ATF, FBI, BOOTS ON THE GROUND
HERE AND THAT'S NOT INCLUDING
ALL OF THE AUSTIN POLICE
OFFICERS AND BOMB SQUADS BROUGHT
IN FROM HOUSTON PD AND THE REST.
THEY ARE FLOODING IT WITH
RESOURCES SO THEY CAN FOLLOW UP
ON EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEIR
TIPS.
THE PRIMARY MESSAGE BEING SENT
TO THE PUBLIC IS TO REMAIN
VIGILANT AND IF YOU SEE
SOMETHING, SAY SOMETHING.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY AND ARE REPORTING.
WE ARE USED TO DOING THAT AT,
SAY, THE AIRPORT OR BIG PUBLIC
EVENT, THE SUPER BOWL.
A GAME OR SOMETHING.
HOWEVER NOT SO MUCH WHEN YOU ARE
IN A RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD OR
IF YOU'RE IN A McDONALD'S OR
SOMETHING, LET'S SAY.
THEY'RE ASKING PEOPLE IF YOU SEE
SOMETHING, DO NOT TOUCH IT.
CALL POLICE SO THEY CAN COME
FOLLOW UP ON IT.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Juan: CASEY, WHAT ABOUT
COPYCATS?
IS THIS THE WORK OF ONE PERSON
OR MULTIPLE PEOPLE?
IS THERE ANYTHING LIKE THAT
THAT'S GIVING US SOME HINT AS TO
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
AND I HAVE A FOLLOW-UP.
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION
BECAUSE THERE IS CONCERN ALWAYS
WITH COPYCAT CRIMES AND THAT ONE
OF THE REASONS POLICE SAY THEY
ARE BEING VERY GUARDED WITH THE
INFORMATION THEY RELEASE.
THAT'S WHY THEY SAY THEY ARE
ONLY SIMILARITIES WITH THE
EXPLOSIVE DEVICES THAT HAVE GONE
OFF SO FAR.
THEY WON'T GO INTO GREAT DETAIL
WITH THAT.
IF THEY RELEASE TOO MUCH
INFORMATION, SOMETHING ONLY THE
BOMBER OR BOMBERS WOULD KNOW
THEMSELVES, THEY DON'T WANT TO
PUT THAT OUT THERE INTO THE
PUBLIC SO THAT PEOPLE A, DON'T
COPY THE CRIME AND B, THEY DON'T
WANT TO JEOPARDIZE THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T BELIEVE
THIS IS A COPYCAT SITUATION.
IT COULD BE THE WORK OF ONE
PERSON OR MORE, THEY SAY.
FRANKLY, THEY SIMPLY DON'T KNOW,
JUAN.
>> Juan: A QUICK FOLLOW-UP.
INITIALLY THE TWO PEOPLE WHO
DIED WERE BLACK MEN.
ON THE PART OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
BLACK CAUCUS THAT THEY SHOULD BE
IDENTIFIED AS A TERRORIST ACT
AND YOU HAD THE NAACP SAYING TO
THE BLACK COMMUNITY -- BUT THEN
THE LAST TWO PEOPLE INJURED WERE
WHITE.
SO WHERE DOES THAT STAND?
>> WELL, IT KIND OF THROUGH THE
WHOLE TARGETING MOTIVE
POTENTIALLY THAT WAS BEING
DISCUSSED KIND OF OUT THE
WINDOW, IS HOW I GATHERED IT
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT YESTERDAY.
BECAUSE YOU ARE RIGHT, THE FIRST
SEVERAL BOMBINGS, THE FIRST
THREE THAT STARTED ON MARCH 2ND,
1 MAN WAS KILLED AND THEN TEN
DAYS LATER, TWO PEOPLE KILLED IN
A SINGLE BLAST.
THESE WERE ALL PACKAGES THAT
WERE LEFT ON A PORCH.
THEY DIDN'T GO THROUGH A
DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
THEY WEREN'T MAILED.
THEY WERE JUST DROPPED OFF THE
PORCH OVERNIGHT.
AND THEN THE PEOPLE OPEN THEM OR
MOVED THEM AND CAUSED THE
EXPLOSION.
THE VICTIMS WERE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN OR LATINO.
AND THESE WERE IN EAST AUSTIN,
TRADITIONALLY KNOWN AS A LOWER
INCOME AREA, IF YOU WELL.
SO THAT'S WHERE THAT THEORY CAME
OUT THAT THEY MIGHT'VE BEEN
TARGETING SPECIFIC GROUPS OF
PEOPLE, A HATE CRIME.
BUT WITH THE TRIPWIRE BEING PUT
ON THE DEVICE SUNDAY, POLICE SAY
THAT MEANT IT WAS DESIGNED TO
HURT ANYBODY WHO DISCOVERED IT.
NOT A SPECIFIC PERSON.
THAT KIND OF TOOK THE WEIGHT OUT
OF THE ARGUMENT A LITTLE BIT.
>> Kimberly: CASEY, THANK YOU.
WE WILL TAKE IT AROUND THE
TABLE.
GREG, YOUR THOUGHTS, IN TERMS OF
THE FACTS AND WITH THE POLICE
AND AUTHORITIES KNOW SO FAR.
RELUCTANT IN THE MIDDLE OF
INVESTIGATION TO GIVE OUT SOME
SIGNATURE ELEMENTS OF THE BOMBS
AND HOW THEY COMPARED OR THEY
ARE DISSIMILAR.
>> Greg: CLEARLY WE DON'T KNOW
MUCH FROM THAT.
THESE EVENTS SHOW ONCE AGAIN HOW
AN INDIVIDUAL OR A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS CAN COMMAND AN
AUDIENCE AND ITS AS CONTAGIOUS
AS IT IS ALLURING.
COULD BE COPYCATS, COULD BE THE
MEDIA FOCUSES ON IT SO HEAVILY
THAT IT'S IRRESISTIBLE.
THE CHALLENGE IN THIS WORLD IS
TO SOMEHOW FIGHT THIS NUMERICAL
SIGNIFICANCE WHERE ONE PERSON, A
SHOOTER OR BOMBER OR TERRORIST,
CAN AFFECT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
OR IN FACT MILLIONS BECAUSE ALL
OF THE NETWORK COVERAGE.
HE'S ALREADY AFFECTED THE WORLD.
IT WILL BE SEEN AS A SUCCESS.
MEANWHILE, THE REAL LESSON FROM
ALL THIS IS THAT, YOU KNOW, EVIL
DEEDS SUCCEED WITH PROPER
PLANNING.
AS LONG AS YOU PLAN AHEAD.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT VEGAS.
WE KNOW NOTHING.
THE REASON WHY WE DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING IS BECAUSE HE PLANNED
FOR TWO YEARS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO PLAN.
YOU KNOW, A HALF A PLAN CANNOT
GO UP AGAINST A FULL PLAN.
CLEARLY THIS IS A PLANNED EVENT.
WE HAVE TO LEARN, WE HAVE TO
PLAN AGAINST THESE PLANNERS.
HE WHO PLANS WINS.
>> Kimberly: ALL RIGHT.
DANA.
>> Dana: I KNOW AS OF
YESTERDAY THEY HAD 500 FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ON THE
GROUND IN ORDER TO HELP.
THAT PROBABLY HAS DOUBLED, AND
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
AUSTIN.
OR YOU HAVE TO BE VIGILANT
BECAUSE COPYCATS, IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING ON NATIONAL MEDIA,
COPYCATS CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE IN
THE COUNTRY.
THE RESOURCES REQUIRED IN ORDER
TO DEAL WITH THINGS LIKE THIS
DOVE TO DISRUPT PLANS, IF YOU
CAN.
IF NOT, THEN DEAL WITH THE
AFTERMATH.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS ARE HAVING A BIG
PROBLEM ON OUR HANDS BECAUSE
THEY GOT A LOT OF RESOURCES, A
LOT OF THINGS THEY NEED TO SPEND
MONEY ON AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
MONEY TO GO AROUND.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
ECONOMIC GROWTH WHICH THANKFULLY
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
BUT PLANNING AHEAD.
THESE TYPES OF THINGS ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE.
IT'S NOT JUST LOCALIZED ANYMORE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO JUST BE IN
AUSTIN.
IT'S GOING TO BE ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
>> Jesse: I WILL SPECULATE
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT REALLY
ANYTHING ELSE TO TALK ABOUT.
IT'S NOT ISIS IN MY OPINION
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SPECTACULAR AND
THERE'S NO VIDEO AND THEY HAVE
NOT CLAIMED CREDIT FOR IT SO
FAR.
THE RACIAL ANGLE WAS INTERESTING
BECAUSE IN THE BEGINNING IT WAS
THREE MINORITIES.
THEN IT WAS TWO WHITE MEN.
I DON'T LIKE HOW IT BECOME SO
RACIALIZED IN THE BEGINNING.
BUT THEY ARE STILL LEAVING IT
OPEN.
LET'S PUT THAT ASIDE.
TO ME, IT LOOKS LIKE A SERIAL
KILLER WHO DOESN'T WANT TO GET
HIS HANDS DIRTY.
SOMEONE WHO ENJOYS TOYING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
GAMESMANSHIP OF IT ALL.
AND SOMEONE WHO I THINK IS GOING
TO GET CAUGHT PRETTY SOON
BECAUSE THERE'S VIDEO CAMERAS
ALL OVER THESE DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS.
WHENEVER YOU DROP OFF A PACKAGE.
THERE'S GOING TO BE SURVEILLANCE
FOOTAGE.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMEONE
SOPHISTICATED BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TRIPWIRE TECHNOLOGY.
SO IT'S NOT AN IDIOT.
BUT IT'S NOT SOMEONE CIA, NOT
THAT HIGH LEVEL.
OBVIOUSLY IT SOMEONE WHO GETS
THEIR MATERIALS FROM A LOCAL
STORE, FROM WHAT WE ARE HEARING
FROM THE SENATORS.
MAYBE AN ANARCHIST.
SOMEONE WHO LIKES DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO TELL.
IT'S JUST SAD BECAUSE TEXAS AND
FLORIDA AT THIS POINT HAVE
SUFFERED SO GREATLY IN THE PAST
YEAR, WHETHER IT'S NATIONAL
DISASTERS, SHOOTINGS, BOMBINGS.
IT TAKES A SPECIAL TYPE OF
CITIZEN IN THESE TWO STATES TO
RECKON WITH IT, AND TEXAS, LIKE
THEY ALWAYS DO, IS DOING A VERY
GOOD JOB.
>> Kimberly: ALSO I THINK
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THEY HAVE
AN UNEXPLODED DEVICE THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO STUDY
WHICH IS GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO NOT
LEAVE SOME KIND OF TRACE OF DNA
OR FORENSICS THAT COULD BE A
CLUE.
THEN YOU HAVE ALL THE PIECES AND
PARTS INTACT, CHASE BACK --
TRACE BACK THE ORIGINATION.
LOOK TO SEE ANY SIMILARITIES
THERE AND THE CONSTRUCTION OF IT
CAN ACTUALLY SHOW THE DETAIL OF